Hey, what's going on is bill barn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday, uh,
November 24th,
2014 2014. How are you,
what's going on? Once again,
I'm recording it nice and
early Monday morning. Uh,
you know,
so I gotta keep my freaking voice down.
I don't want to disturb the construction.
It's winding down everybody.
It's winding down. They painted
the fucking walls, you know.
Well it goes a couple of little
bit of electrical things.
A couple of big bank boons, which of
course will take for fucking ever. Um,
I actually found out that I need a new
electrical panel outside my house because,
uh, the one that I had was, uh, you know,
just a hunk of shit and
a, so I go out. Right.
So take the one off that I have
and put a new one there. Right.
And this fucking governmental cont right.
He shows up with this fucking tape measure
and he said there was no safe way for
his guys to put a ladder up because they
had this fucking palm tree thing. Right.
Which now, and even natural. Okay.
To the ecosystem out here.
Some jerk off,
liked him way back in the day and
stuck a fucking coconut on his boat or
whatever the hell the seed is, right?
Is that the seat of a palm tree?
Is it a coconut or is that the fruit?
It bears and within the coconut
there's the seed. I don't know.
Um, so anyways, so he goes, Nah,
the only place we can stick it is right
on the back of your fucking house where
it's going to be the ugliest
ever. And I'm like, well no,
we're not putting it there. And he's
like, Claire worked for the government,
right?
So he goes to get out there
and his government issued
Ford escort station wagon
number, those fucking things. Um,
so I had to call the
guy up and he's got a,
he's got to cut this fucking tree down.
And I know what you're thinking. Well,
wait a minute. I thought you were fucking,
uh, oh, Billy tree hugger, you know,
or William Environment. A William
tell their right of the fucking guy.
The guy who wrote about a lake
Winnipesaukee there. Walden Lake.
Who was that fucking boring cunt
that wrote all the poems. You know,
everybody was freaking out,
all this shit he was saying he was
plagiarizing the native Americans.
They already fucking knew. They already
knew it was a great lake. All right?
They have fucking a twinkle
toes with your stupid poems.
The date of Americans had it right the
way they will live and they lived off the
fucking land. They didn't take more
than they need that they needed. Right.
And when you got sick,
some weird guy and you're fucking tribe
did a dance around you and then you died
and that was it. Okay. And
it kept the herd thinned out.
Okay.
No,
he came out there with some,
the skull of a fucking snake
or some shit on his head.
Okay.
Putting line dance into shame is what
this guy did. And then you fucking die.
That's, it was fucking over.
Hey, you had a great 30 years.
See Ya. Whatever. They deny its natural.
Geronimo, he lived for a while, didn't he?
He used to get the senior citizen discount
when he took the stage coach after a
while, you know, wants to white man
took over. Isn't that what happened?
Okay.
Oh fuck that again on this subject.
Oh yeah. Taking down the fucking tree.
So now I've got to take down this.
Just I could take down this fucking,
so basically I'm like, all right,
so what if I take out the tree
that really shouldn't even be here,
that provides shade in
an area that you know,
never had shade because it's actually a
fucking desert. And you know, by the way,
what are we all doing out here?
Huh?
We're all standing around
trying to get a fucking
goddamn guest star on the
reboot of fucking Tj Hooker.
Why are we out here as fucking place?
Just freaks me out.
Absolutely. Freaks me out. Um, anyways,
uh, so now I got, I got that. So
then whatever, so they got it,
then they'll put the panel on and then
my electrical system will be complete.
I can actually turn lights on in my
house and not worry that somewhere in my
house does a little flash of fire when
I throw a switch because that's what was
going on. That was going on
while I had a minor gas leak.
It's fucking unreal.
I'm going to tell you right now,
whoever buys this house
after me is going to be,
they're not even going to realize the
Goddamn goldmine that they walked into
cause all this shit that I'm doing,
it does not add value to my house.
This is all shit that should have been
done right to begin with. You know,
it's just when somebody, you
know, inspect your house,
they can't look into the walls.
All they're looking for is the sweat
marks on the walls and the cracks and can
you roll a marble across the floor, you
know, without even giving any effort.
You know, they just looking at shit like
that. You know, he was getting home.
They go walk on your roof.
They go up there and they have a sandwich
and rubbed their balls for a couple of
seconds. It's probably could have
made and leafs and that's it.
What's it gonna get a bad recommendation?
I don't remember who it was.
You think I can find that guy's
business card to warn other people? Oh,
by the way, this guy came back with
the little glint in his eye and said,
is the great,
has you guys will be very happy and
gradually you get yourself a great house.
Um, anyways, so whoever comes in
next and then this is the thing,
they won't even appreciate it.
Just like the rich kids son,
you know,
the son of a guy who
fucking pulled himself up
by his bootstraps, you know,
gotten into insider trading.
You know, fucking bootleg some
booze across the fucking God damn.
Whatever the fuck it is. One of
those great lakes. I was like,
fuck fucking Greg.
Right?
Then he goes out and buy some palatial
estate. He gets himself a trophy wife.
He gets on top of her right, boom.
Nine months later,
here comes this fucking jerk off.
He's born with one of those fucking,
uh,
you call the other one little piece
of glass in your eye. Not a false,
a monocle. He doesn't get rattled.
He doesn't get a baby fucking bear.
They give them a Monica.
Let's how fucking rich this kid isn't.
He actually has a little
fucking a pocket watch.
He's got a little pocket in his diaper.
That's how much money this
fucking kid is born into.
And you think he gives a shit. He
sits around and he's bored, right?
Yeah.
Grabs a handful of Molly and
starts rubbing up against
the suit of armor in the
fucking house. Right? That's
what the fuck he does.
You think he gives a shit
or even even fucking knows
that he's got state of the Ark,
state of the art fucking electricity
in, in, in copper piping going through
that fucking 9,000 square foot Cabana. No,
he doesn't cheat bill. You're kind of
making yourself out to be a martyr.
I am
anyways. Okay. It's fucking
shit. Seven in the morning.
I'm already getting fucking text messages.
Yeah,
just never fuck it. Never fucking
ends. It never ends. So anyways,
so that's the latest thing was this,
this thing.
We got the hardwood floors in and a
couple of you guys said, you know,
after you've been bitching about this
for so long, you have better sense.
You better put up some pictures. You
know what I say to you? Fuck you.
You're not seeing one goddamn picture my
downstairs I am painting a picture with
the beautiful words of
this wonderful language.
Now I'm not showing you what the
inside of my house looks like.
Yeah,
you want me to upload what the inside
of my fucking house looks like?
So then what you guys can say,
it looks like shit and that I got ripped
off and then I'm a fucking big headed
moron. You think? I don't understand
how you guys operate at this point.
I may have a Charlie Brown fucking head,
but if you think I'm going to walk up
and try to kick that football again,
you're out of your fucking
mind. All right? So anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Everybody, if you're new to it, welcome.
If you're from another country,
you stay put, you stay,
you stay right where you are. We
don't need you anymore. All right.
Okay.
We're doing just fine with the immigrants
that were abusing over here right now.
You sit the fuck down.
I don't even know what's going on.
There's some sort of immigration thing
going on in the news and everybody's
fucking flapping their arms.
You're right.
And the guys in the red ties are
going again. I'm the fuck Outta here.
And the guys in the blue ties or like,
you know,
I think everybody should have
a right to be here. Right?
Same Old fucking shit. I love when
they go like, well the immigrants,
you know, they do the jobs that
Americans don't want to do.
I love how that,
they always put it back on
like they always get it off.
The rich guys like immigrants do the jobs.
Americans don't want to do that.
That's such a fucking brilliant way of
saying that Americans don't want to be
grossly underpaid for back,
back breaking work that makes somebody
else's Zillion fucking dollars.
Do you think those immigrants
want to do those jobs?
And I love when they sit there and go over
this. They're happy. The fucking happy
bent over at the waist all
day picking jelly beans.
You want to fucking do that
out and candy land fields.
I don't think anybody wants to,
they're basically saying we can't get
away with sweatshop labor in this country
anymore because of unions. All right.
And then they, but they spin it around.
They got the Americans
don't want to do this job.
You're telling me you can find an American
to go out and go pick some fucking
apples if you paid them right?
Huh?
We'll fuck would want to go on and go
pick some apples. You get that bag right?
You're walking around out in the fucking
air. Nobody breathing down your neck.
You just up there picking
apples like Johnny Appleseed.
I'd love to be a fucking
apple picker if you paid me,
you know you want to give me 30 sets of
fucking month ago. Pick apples. Yeah,
go fuck yourself. You pick the fucking
apples. You'll see that that Elena,
they're there and have a work ethic
you just crushed anyways.
Okay.
Gotta go find some guy that used to sleep
on a rock under a fucking waterfall to
do that God damn job because she
did. Some guy walked here, you know,
from Zimbabwe,
grab herself a piece of fucking oak or
whatever. Some light p pine or some shit.
Right. Doggy paddled his whole
fucking way over here. Yeah.
You think he's scared of picking some
apples for no money doesn't give a fuck.
He's happy to be back on the land.
You got to go to that fucking guy,
that level of struggle in life
to find somebody to go out to go,
you know, roll the cantaloupes
in after the fucking harvest.
Right.
Why?
Because we don't want to do it because
we won't fucking work for a dollar a
month. You rich cunt. Oh,
I'm on a fucking tear this
morning. Unbelievable. Um,
so anyways,
so that putting the tile in the bathroom,
we're getting down to it right now. We're
getting down and I, and this is what I,
this is what I've learned from this
fucking job. This is what you do.
If you ever get any
work done in your house,
have the whole fucking thing designed
okay?
Before you know you wet,
you have them even fucking removed.
The first piece of fucking whatever
you have the whole thing designed.
You have everything that you want put in
there and you already have that fucking
thing priced out.
Then you order all the shit
before they even start.
You order all the fucking shit that you
want put back. He put in a new kitchen,
you order all of the shit
that you want put back in,
and you'd stick it in your fucking garage,
and then you fucking take out a stop
watch and you go, all right, guys, go,
and that's it.
Then you stay on top of them.
You never fucking stop me actually in
the estimate to you include the shit that
they're gonna put in afterwards because
he's fucking assholes. If you go, yeah.
What's the estimate to, yeah. You know,
to get a new kitchen put in on
the Gwalia 10 grand, you know,
10 grand is for them to disassemble
the shit you have. You know,
forget about all the bullshit they're
gonna find in the walls. Will,
you'll only a little
of bro Lou Lu,
the slew of WHO's looked up to code this,
These v three go to the
vintage of the Zulu,
Google, all that fucking shits common.
And then on top of all of that,
they're going to add the
price for all of them.
Imply answers and all the counters,
all the countertops and all that.
And you'd be like, wait a minute,
this wasn't in the estimate
and they're going to be like, uh, no.
You know what you feel
like when you're doing,
it's like the blues brothers when they
thought the beer was free. Yeah, like a,
he didn't look good.
Charges fill the first one.
So why we thought they
were like a break a half?
Nah, Nah. That's what you're
contracted does. All right.
There's no difference between buying a
car and having some fucking asshole work
on your house. You have no idea
what the price is. You know,
like when you go down to buy a car,
which you want to get from those cons,
is the out the door price out the door?
What is this costing me?
They'll fucking act like you knock in the,
ah,
take a grand off and then charge you 1500
bucks for the fucking, uh, Russ. Perfect.
You know,
I don't know.
This is just the ramblings of
someone born without pigment. Okay.
Why would you listen to this
shit? Uh, all right, let's,
let's do a little bit of advertising here
and then we're going to talk some shit
here. Like I haven't been
already. Um, all right.
Where the hell is it? What are we, what
are we reading here this week? Oh Shit.
Draft Kings. Everybody. Millionaires
are being made all season,
all seasonLong@draftkings.com America's
favorite one week fantasy football site.
Far as I'm concerned, they're the only
one. Are there others? I don't know.
One week fantasy means no seasoned long
commitments. Play whenever you want.
Do you have an injured player?
No problem. Exclamation point.
At draftkings.com it's like
a new season every week.
So you're never stuck with the same place.
Pick your team and pick
your team in minutes
and you could be on your way to winning
huge cash down goes Frazier down goes
Frazier. Uh, this season,
one listener turned 10 bucks into $5,000.
Yeah, I wonder what he did with that
pretty well and had a keg party, right.
Bought himself a fucking yeah.
Cavalier Gt.
Um,
another turn tooth out $2 into 10 grand.
Okay.
And
a new
millionaire
has
been
crowned@nearlyeveryweekthisseasonatdraftkings.com
just to let you know, if you win 1 million
bucks, it's 500 grand after taxes. Uh,
you could be next.
Imagine winning $1 million in one day.
Just playing fantasy
football@draftkings.com call to action.
Get a free get free entry into their
hundred thousand dollar fantasy football
contest this weekend where
first place takes home 10 grand.
What
$100,000 fantasy football contest
and then you'll win 10 grand.
Yeah,
it will. Jesus. Just a good old boy.
A head to drive kings.com now
and enter Promo code crap.
Is this my fucking copy?
So he's telling me this is a different
fucked enter, cracked. Enter
bill or rent a burpee. You are.
See what the fuck happens to play for
free@draftkings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings, bigger millionaires.
Enter bill or [inaudible] or bill Barth.
Get up,
do whatever you want for free entry
now@draftkings.com draftkings.com that's
[inaudible] dot com all right,
the man great everybody.
Okay.
What better way to show your dad that
you love them then to upgrade his grill?
You know when you're a married man,
what do you have? You have your garage,
you have your grill and you
have your boots, that's it.
And you'll walk out in the living
room and you sit down eating a burger,
the dust on you from the garage, and
you suck down a fucking whiskey, right?
And you're looking at your wife
and you see your mouth moving,
but you know fucking hearing
because you're enjoying
the taste of a God damn man
Burger cooked on a fucking man.
Great Attention Grill
Masters this holiday season,
there's only one gift that is an
absolute must have the man. Great.
Just don't stick it in. Somebody's
stalking you. Stupid fuck. What's a man?
Great.
You ask man grates are American made
high quality 100% cast iron grill grates
that sit right on top
of your existing greats.
Yeah.
Can you believe it? Weighing in,
weighing in at eight pounds a piece. Man.
Greats insured juicy,
tender meat with no flareups
and perfect sear marks.
What are we talking about here?
We're talking about meat or just some
homoerotic novel that sounds like a
disease free dick that they were
just describing. Um, anyways, man.
Greats patented design delivers steakhouse
quality and flavor right at your
home. Take advantage of the
Monday morning podcast special and
get 33% off your order.
Also for a limited time for every
free man. Great shoe order. Jesus.
How many dads do you have? You
get a fourth man, great for free.
Just so just head over
to [inaudible] dot com
okay.
Then enter that my coupon code
burpee you are are at checkout.
Here's the bullet points. Everybody
there, 100% made in America.
They're 100% cast iron and you
get 33% off your entire order.
And when you went to birth,
B u r r a checkout, it's a
limited for a limited time,
you can order three man grates
and get the fourth one for free.
I don't understand what more you need.
All right,
make sure to go to [inaudible]
dot com and enter my coupon code,
Bar B U R R at checkout. So there
you go. I'm showing you how to be
a smarter gambler.
All right,
I'm showing you how to make a good steak.
What more do you need?
How about a nice shave? What do I got
here? I got to level do those two later.
All right, let's, let's, let's get back
into the podcast here. Um, all right.
So
last night I had Paul
Versey on speakerphone and
I had Jason lie ahead in my
living room and we had a couple of pops.
Paul was driving home or whatever,
and uh, we had this epic
fucking argument. Um,
it all started off with that guy in the
giants making that unbelievable catch,
which immediately everybody started
saying was the greatest catch of all time,
greatest catch of all time.
And of course Paul Versey,
there's nothing Paul likes better than
saying that something is the greatest of
all time. And I'm just like
Paul, that's without a doubt.
It's got to be top two or three.
And I'm saying that out of respect for
the fact that I know I haven't seen every
great fucking catch.
Okay.
In Nfl fucking history.
I know I have it just out of respect,
but I know God damn well. I'm trying to
think of a better one that I ever saw. No,
I don't think I can think of one.
This bigger catches catches that happen,
the Superbowl, but just as far as degree
of difficulty, without a doubt, that's,
I mean, I, I
wouldn't think that you could maybe find
one or two better than that. All right.
But I do remember back in the day when I
used to watch a Boston college and this
kid with a mesh half shirt was
fucking running full speed,
jumped up in the air and with one hand
just fucking reached back in behind his
head and fucking just snag this
ball out like a fucking eagle.
BC, Eagle. Yeah. There you
go. Just snatched it out.
Right. And when I, you know,
was trying to find that catch on
the Internet, I couldn't find it.
So this is what verse he says he goes to.
He's like,
Chris Carter just said it's the greatest
catch of all time. It's like Paul,
that's his fucking job.
Okay.
Oh Hey.
It's his fucking job.
Espns job is to tell you every fucking
night that what you saw or what you're
about to see is the greatest fucking
thing you're ever going to see.
Cause that's how they
get their whore money.
That's how they can afford to go
out there and get the corvette.
Z O six with the fucking,
uh, look at me over here.
Fucking racing package.
Yeah.
Message. I know Chris Card is a
fucking hall of fame wide receiver,
but I mean come on the second you get on
TV, you got to start flapping your arms.
Okay. If they don't hear you, your,
you're fucking sport coat
bumping up against you, Mike.
They're not going to give
you your paycheck. All right.
Look what happened to herm Edwards.
Herm Edwards was a respectable human
being when he played football and he
coached football. Then he got on TV.
I don't know what happened to the guy.
That guy should have a red fucking
nose on one of those horns out. Oh God.
Every time he fucking said something,
I don't even know if
he's still on the show.
Okay.
I don't know if it was TV or he just
snapped her in that one loss where he,
you know, you play to win the
games. If he just fucking,
something in his head just snapped because
he goes on ESPN and he talks real low
like this when he's setting up his point.
And then when he goes to make his point
that he started fucking screaming, right?
Yeah.
Starts doing the curly
shuffle, right. Wise Guy. Um,
so anyways,
okay.
Anyways, so first he goes, dude, I
just googled greatest catches ever.
Yeah,
it goes, it's a joke to say that
Lynn Swann catching the Superbowl.
It's almost insulting.
I love that. He just,
he calls on the Internet. He doesn't even
Google greatest one handed catch him.
He just,
Google's greatest catch ever.
And then he sits down and watches
some dentists youtube video.
This guy, right? This fucking guy.
He just puts this together and then
that's it. That's, there you go.
That's how I know some guy
who works on ESPN shed.
It's the greatest one ever.
And then I watched some fucking random
guy's youtube video and there you go.
That's it. It's done. Come on guys.
This is what I would love it to be the
greatest fucking catch of all time.
All right.
But I got to tell you,
he only did it last night and
according to my research, okay,
in a 12 hour period,
you cannot watch every great
fucking catch of all fucking time,
professional and college
level in all of that shit.
But I will tell you that that
was definitely, I mean there,
there's no way that you could find two
catches better than that. I will say that,
but I'm going to stop short of
Paul Versey slash Tony Kornheiser,
which I'll never forget in September of
2007 watching the New England patriots
is just the greatest team ever. And
then they end up losing the super bowl.
It's like,
you know,
you know what's his real travesty is that
Tony Kornheiser doesn't wear a fucking
toupee that's barely on his head.
You know what I mean?
Then you could actually see how over
the top half the shit the guys like that
say,
cause every time they snap their head
would go flying on the and it would remind
you to take it with a grain of salt.
That for as much as Tony
Kornheiser knows what he's saying.
He's standing in the middle of a three
ring circus going ladies and gentlemen,
boys and girls,
children of all ages.
This is look great.
Isn't bad mitten championship deals.
Wheel does have a fucking child.
Um,
so we went from that to then on,
I fucking phone is blowing
up here. Oh, conference call,
conference call. I don't do conference
calls when they have a conference call.
No,
and neither do you,
none of us want to be on this
fucking phone call right now.
Can somebody just say the thing that
needs to be said so we can all hang up?
Can I tell you something?
One of the greatest things about
doing what I do for a living is, uh,
I don't have to have,
you know, there's no, um,
like meetings. I don't want to tread on
some shit that I did. Oh, by the way,
I forgot to mention last week my,
uh,
comedians in cars getting
coffee aired last week. And, um,
you know, I was actually talking
to Mr Seinfeld, by the way.
That was one of the most surreal fucking
things I've ever done to be sitting
there with him. The king, um,
nobody did this business better.
Why? I can't say flip Wilson
did it. Johnny Carson did
it. Will you just go out?
You hit him, you hit him hard, you get
your money, and then you walk away.
All right? And as they're talking
on your shirt going, hey, hey,
you want to try to make a comeback?
Do you want to try to do something
else so we can just cancel it?
You don't want to put a little fucking
black stain up against your name.
And they just go, no, you know what?
I'm good. You, you, you enjoy yourself,
Hollywood. I'll see you later.
Flip Wilson did that flip.
Wilson had his fucking show.
He was smart with his money.
He invested his shit and when the
show was done, he's like, I'm out.
See you later. Go Fuck
Yourself. If you need me,
I'll be at home rubbing my balls,
watching the game for the rest
of my fucking life. Right?
Johnny Carson, he did. He
ended up owning the show.
He had his own fucking clothing line. You
know, long before all those rappers did,
okay? They're all ripping off Johnny
Carson, Johnny Carson collection,
some of the greatest plaid three piece
suits you ever saw in your fucking life
on it. You can laugh at them,
you can laugh at it, but you
laugh at them, all right?
You're saying you don't like
anchorman if you don't like anchorman,
you know what an American and according
to some of the people I've seen
screaming on TV, that means you need
to get the fuck out of this country.
How dumb is that? Countries? You know,
why can't we all just be happy?
We're not in the water, right?
Can everybody just fucking relax? Okay, I
get shoes. She gets sandals. How are you?
How's it going? Great. You know, I don't
know what that thing is on your head,
but you know, you seem to enjoy it. You
want to come home and have some dinner?
Why? Why can't? Why can't
you just fucking do that?
Why does it always have to be
screaming and fucking yelling?
Goddamn Isis Horse Shit.
I swear to fucking Christ.
I would love to see them try to
fucking defeat Florida. You know,
sitting there acting like
they were a god damn problem.
Holy Shit is fucking 30,000 people on
the other side of the planet that don't
like us. Well thank God we're
on this side of the planet.
I know we just stay over here and figure
out how to make our cars run on Legos
and then what are they gonna be mad
at that they got nobody to shoot it?
Fuck them. Okay. You know
what it is about America.
We'd like back in the day,
like one of those big fucking ANR guys
that could actually take a band out of a,
pluck them out of obscurity
and give them a hit record.
That's what America does
with our foreign policy.
No one would ever have heard
of isis if it wasn't for us.
If our a and R guys didn't go over there
and pluck them out of fucking obscurity,
they'd just be over there,
you know?
No one would even know they'd
be like a garage band, you know,
blowing up shit over there. Didn't know
what would even fucking about. All right,
why don't we walk away, tear up their
contract and just fucking come on.
Why don't we just come home? Can
we just do, hey everybody corner.
Let's just come up enough already. You're
not going to solve anything over there.
All right. But we want the stuff in
the grout. I mean, sorry, we're trying.
Trying to give them freedom.
That's right. Come on,
grow up. Okay. But just come on.
Okay, we have beaches over here.
What are you doing up? We've
got an oil here. Um, anyways,
that was my version of what we
should do with their foreign policy.
Having not read a God damn thing about it.
As far as I know,
isis was some sexy,
broadened the seventies you know,
who was a rival to a wonder woman.
You know,
cause everybody knows good looking
bitches don't get along. And the only way,
the only way to good looking women get
along is it's so they can hate on other
good looking women and just sit there,
you know,
at the faces all fucking scrunched
up. Hey, why does your face age?
But the rest of your body doesn't
or why does your face age faster?
You know that like you have a sheet,
like an old strip or the fucking bodies
are gorgeous and then their face,
she's like, wow man, look at that body.
That body looks 26 and you look
at their face, ah, she's 42,
Amit for instance.
You know what I mean?
Like if you guys saw me completely
fucking naked, if be like, wow, man,
I bet that guy's like 31 and then you
see my face. She's like, Holy Shit,
let's pick out a plot. I'm sorry.
You know what? I'm not sorry.
You deserve that. You deserve to
picture me naked. Um, so anyway,
so we ended up having this fucking
ridiculous fucking argument where,
uh,
Paul Versey of course was saying Babe
Ruth was the greatest baseball player of
all time.
And then he said all the usual shit.
He basically repeated shit that he heard
on TV that he played at the dead ball
era. Right. And a law head was also
trying to tell me, you know, yeah.
He, and I was just saying, listen,
I'm not saying he's not one of
the great players of all time,
but he's not the greatest of all
fucking time for the simple fact,
he didn't play against the greatest.
All right.
He played in a segregated
league with the Pedro Martinez.
The Mariano Rivera is okay.
The Josh Gibson,
they weren't allowed
in the fucking league.
He didn't have to compete
against Reggie Jackson.
He didn't have to compete against these
guys. They weren't allowed in the league.
He was playing and basically
a softball league. Okay.
With the top third would, I
would say, would make, you know,
would make the major league baseball
nowadays. Okay. But I get it.
You gotta think like two thirds of
it wouldn't even fucking Ben there.
Then they tried to do that shit.
Well, Bill, who was only 10 teams,
there's dirty teeth now.
Yeah.
There was all solely fucking 2
billion people on the planet.
Now there's 7 billion.
Yeah.
All right, so I'll, I'll,
I'll knock off like I'll get my next
to 10% on his fucking numbers then.
Okay.
Like give me a fucking
break all you gotta do.
Okay.
Do he play baseball when
people die to tuberculosis?
He played baseball like there
was a hit song, but at the
[inaudible] and that song was written in
the 1890s and everybody thought it was
too fucking crazy. What is
this devil music? God dammit.
She, what happens when you let them
off the plantation? They get a piano.
They couldn't even handle it.
Bought up
[inaudible] he played baseball.
That was a hit.
Baba Du,
Du,
du Du du De de de de Beauvoir
devil by de Boop, boop,
boop, boop, boop, boop, boop. You know,
people would just hear it and then sit
around wondering when they were ever
going to hear it again because they had
no device to play it on. Yeah. That idea,
that double Babu,
right?
That guy came to town and everybody
stood around him and I played,
played a fucking piano.
You see how they worked out back
then? Head, shoulders, knees and toes,
knees and toes. Head, shoulders, knees and
toes. Knees and toes. And only white guys.
No plaques. I Puerto Ricans, head,
shoulders, knees and toes. These are jobs.
Yeah.
The big dumb fucking gloves that
looked like little people hands.
Give me a fucking break.
Okay.
Not to mention Babe Ruth. I mean they
built a stadium towards his strength.
That right field fence. Okay. You could,
you could make a cop show.
Yeah,
with two toddlers and they could do the
classic scene with a fucking cop chases
the perp down the alley and he gets to
the chain link fence and fucking jumps
over it. You could, you could
film that with two toddlers,
with the right field fence in Yankee
stadium. The House that Ruth built.
All right?
He backed up to catch a fly ball.
It hits you like mid thigh and you
fell into some guy's lap, right?
So anyway, give me a fucking break. All
right. From 1930 on, I'll give it to you.
All right? But if you played in
the teams, he played in the arts,
he played in the 18 hundreds and even
into the twenties go fuck yourself.
All right. And I feel like
every look, every like, um,
major sport has their three stooges era
where one team won a bunch of fucking
championships. All right. I love the
Boston Celtics, but gimme a break.
You look at them in the 1960s.
I mean,
it looks like it looks like a game
being played at the y, you know,
some Christian rec league.
All right?
The fucking Canadians won a bunch
of Stanley cups when, you know,
you had first dibs on any guy within
a 300 mile fucking radius and it's 16
fucking league.
They had first dibs on anybody
in French speaking Quebec.
And we had, you know, we had first pick
had like the best guy from Vermont. Gee,
did you go on a run? It's
fucking ridiculous. Okay.
And then the Green Bay packers who were
actually the fucking Yankees of football,
you know, they, you know, they were,
when entitles when the Canton bulldogs,
we're still in the fucking leg. All
right. Hey Man, give me, come on. Right?
Football was like a genie. I think they
played with a pumpkin back then. I mean,
give me a fucking break. All those little
star, the house during the blah, blah,
the only ones that I will then I will,
I will recognize the championships
without a grain of salt. I would say,
uh,
any of the New York Yankees from like
the 1930 [inaudible] for the simple fact
they went babe Ruth, Lou Gehrig,
Joe Dimaggio and Mickey Mantle.
That's just, nobody's, nobody's
ever going to do that again.
You're not going to get the Jordan of
your error four times in a fucking roll.
All right? You're just not going
to do it. So without a doubt,
I respect all of that type of shit.
But you know,
at the inception of these
fucking leaks when crazy legs,
Johnson runs around googly eyes fucking
Ulysses and could give me a fucking
break. Okay. He played
in the deadbolt every,
you don't understand
this guy had more devils
who was on the mound?
My great grandfather
got out of the bowl fan. Oh, freckles.
The Bay was that the song they played
when he came in said or enter Sandman.
They weren't facing cut
fast balls back then.
I'm sure there was guys
throwing 90 a hundred miles
a fucking hour, but just the,
the amount of bumps that were in that
fucking league back then. I don't even,
I didn't want to hear it.
Okay.
There's a guy in the hall of fame.
Oh,
for good luck in baseball.
He kept us section of rope
that was used in an actual,
okay,
this is how long ago these fucking people
played and you're going to sit there
and act like in the inception of
these fucking leagues. You know,
I'm looking at, obviously in every era
there, there was a Jordan. All right.
But just like the
techniques and everything,
some of the records
that were set back then,
they didn't have a fucking heavyweight
fight. It would go on for like a day.
They'd have like a fucking,
you know, a 90 round fight.
Okay. Now listen, you're getting
punched in the fucking head,
but what kind of technique are you using?
Phil?
Did bare knuckle fucking the people
bubble God go, fuck. I want to hear it.
I don't want to hear it.
All right.
The competition now is so
much more insane that I,
I just think it would immediately any,
but I guess they would
compete at the same level.
But like just the fact that it's now
everybody gets to compete and not to
mention like, I mean you could
get fucking fathers out there.
I try and they try and teach their kid how
to throw a curve ball to get, you know,
get the family out of the trailer park
when the kids like six years old stunting
the growth of, of one of
his fucking arms, you know,
cause they live in a fucking trailer
and somebody got a growth on their face
that they want to have a year
they want to removed than others.
Kids go on out there.
You know,
back in the day you went out and you
played catch with you little kid.
Now you go out there and you from day one
you try to teach them how to switch it.
It's insane. All right, so
whatever. I'm just saying,
so whatever you guys think,
Babe Ruth is the greatest baseball player.
It's so hard to say because all you
can go by is this guy's fucking stats.
Yeah.
Who you played back,
you know,
there was probably a guy better than
fucking babe Ruth, but he got polio.
You know what I mean? I have, it's
just all right. I'm done. I'm done.
Fucking murderer in here. All
right, let's move on here. Uh Oh,
he's just see the bills and
jets game was snowed out.
I love when they had those
big snow storms, right?
And then everybody goes global warming.
Um,
and I got a buddy of mine for a shot
who was actually on a Conan O'brien last
week. He didn't let me know. You
know, cause like most funny people,
he's fucking humble. Okay. And
didn't even fucking tell me, but, uh,
he actually told me that that
is a symptom of global warming.
And I'm going to pause here for everybody.
You know,
who doesn't think that 7 billion people
pouring nuclear waste into rivers has
any sort of an effect on the planet,
you know, but a bunch of deer do.
We're gonna eat all fucking Troy's. We've
got to get them all here, ma'am. Well,
what about us?
What he might,
we're fine dares having effect
deers having an effect on,
on the environment.
You know them things that don't
drive cars or pollute lakes year,
but 7 billion people
who actually us here who actually put a
hole in the fucking ozone layer spraying
and Pam into skillets, so are
all much. Don't stick to them.
We do not have any sort of
effect on the planet whatsoever.
Um, this, I mean, I don't
know shit about this,
but people are actually
saying that that is, uh,
these giant snow storms or actually a
direct effect of the warming of the globe.
Now, whether we do it or not, here
we go. This is what this person says.
This storms that buried Buffalo New
York area and more than seven feet,
2.1 meters. If you're from another
country [inaudible] of snow this week,
shafted records and shock the residents
even or even in a region accustom,
uh, to dealing with heavy
snow. The storms are certain,
provide new fodder for climate change.
Skeptics who seem to embrace every
monster blizzard as evidence that global
warming doesn't exist.
And yet the science behind
these catastrophic storm
suggest that they do not
occurred despite global warming,
but in fact because of it.
And He sends a link to
the u s India Summit, uh,
bring historic climate
action question mark.
Now I know this person wants it
to be true, so I understand that.
I'm only reading one side of the argument,
but this is,
this is actually interesting to me.
A part of what gave us
the record lake effect.
Snow fall in buffalo was warm late
fall lake surface temperature.
That combined with something
highly unusual, a five sigma event,
Oh shit. The Lek clears it up.
The hell does that mean, uh,
that is a very likely events on the,
on the order of one in a million
or more remarkable persistent,
what's with all the big words, dude,
anomalous configuration of the jet stream,
which brought frigid, frigid Arctic
air down into the United States.
So early in the season,
the cold winds traveling over the warm
moisture laden lake created a perfect
storm of conditions for record.
Uh, for record lake effect snow.
I think basically what they say is warm
air can hold more moisture because the
air molecules are more
spread out in their logic.
Right. And then that
for what? I don't know,
they don't explain why the fucking
jet stream got pushed down,
bringing the so whatever. So frigid
air hit this unbelievably warm air.
All right. And then what does
that do ladies and gentlemen,
we all know that cold air is high pressure
air and high pressure wants to go to
low pressure and then what does it do?
It fucking goes slams into
it and sends all that warm,
moist air right up into the fucking sky.
Right?
Then it hits the dewpoint.
What's the dewpoint boys and girls to do?
Point is the point at which one water,
when moisture in the air becomes visible,
also known as the cloud and it looks
all mcbrown with more known as fob.
Yeah. So then what happens
is as that air moves up,
it starts to cool.
So the air molecules start to shrink and
then you reach the saturation point and
then the fucking water drops. And then
what? That Arctic air underneath it.
It fucking snows like a motherfucker.
All right. Now what happens there?
I don't understand how the, how the
fucking do whatever. Yeah, just it's,
it's interesting. Whatever. If
I'll have the link up there,
if you guys can translate it for
me, I'd appreciate it. There you go.
That was bill Nye the science, not the
science guy. I got some of it right.
You gotta be impressed with the high
pressure, low pressure shit, weren't ya?
We'll go fuck yourself. What are you
impressed by her, your own bulls. Um,
someone who's, what else do I have
to do here? Let me what, I mean,
what else do I have to do for you?
People, you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to read the last two were
advertising this week. You know,
and if you actually paid to advertise
on here and you don't like my reads,
my reads are fucking great because I eve,
as much as I'm shitting on whatever
I'm saying, it keeps people listening.
All right? And they buy stuff. By the
way, guess what I'm wearing a pair of,
I'm wearing a pair of me undies. Me
undies, no more sweaty balls, booboo. Boo.
I'm wearing them.
They send them to me.
MMM.
They seem to be working fine,
but I don't have sweaty ball itis,
so I don't know what to tell you,
but they didn't advertise this week.
So I'll tell you about my experience
later on another episode. All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everyone.
Big Shave companies must think
we're a bunch of scumbag criminals.
Why else did they lock the raises up
in that maximum security plastic razor
fortress in the [inaudible]?
Uh,
you have to stand around like a convict
waiting for the guy to come and unlock
the raise a case. Uh, do they think
you're some kind of a jewel thief?
Well, what if some homeless guy
comes in and shaves his balls?
Any Nix it and then you get,
you get homeless ball aids.
Maybe they're trying to fucking
prevent that. I don't know.
Why am I sticking up for
cvs? Anyways, next thing.
There'll be a security guard who tazes
you. If you get too close to the raises,
you're not a criminal and you shouldn't
be treated like one just because you
need a pack of razors.
Um,
they were sick of getting humiliated
every time they need to raise us.
So they came up with dollar shave club.com
they're playing starts at just $3 a
month. They arrive like clockwork. He can
shave with a fresh blade every week. Uh,
that's the American dream.
Dollar Shave club.com is
the most convenient way to
get a great shave and the
least expensive too.
Maybe if the big shape companies blades
weren't so ridiculously expensive,
they would need to lock them up tighter
than Fort Knox. If anything is criminal,
it's the big shape companies
prices. Absolutely. Absolutely.
And now the big shape companies are trying
to do it when a dollar shave club is
doing all right. Fuck those guys.
Stick with dollar shave club.
You just got off the plantation. You're
a free man. You don't run back onto it.
You're a of dummies. Stick with dollar
shave, club.com. Dollar Shave club.com.
Over a million people get their razors
from dollar shave club.com. All right.
If you're not part of the club,
you're missing out.
Dollar Shave club.com/bur bur um,
go to that now and check them
out. You won't be solid. Sorry.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr
B u. R r. E. Voice. Everybody.
Um, evidently I love the flexibility
that owning your own business provides.
Why do they do that?
Okay,
why? Why? I I, I don't
have my own business,
but evidently I love the flexibility of
it. What else do I love? I don't know.
Let me read more of this copy. Look at
me. I've created an empire with this show.
Uh, but when it comes to
handling, handling business calls,
you're stuck with a challenge and now
we're talking to you all of a sudden,
either hire a full time receptionist
or handle all of your calls yourself.
It's a lose lose.
That's why I love he voice everybody.
They will set up your business.
What the toll free number or a local call.
I actually do. I love this idea.
Okay, I do love this idea. Okay,
but I don't need a voice for
the people that he voiced.
It tells me that I love it. I will
tell them that I love it. If I love it,
the Goddamn it, stop putting more
in my mouth. Um, they will set you,
set up your business with the
toll free number or local number.
When customers call,
they have create,
they're greeted by a professional or a
virtual receptionists that were rotate
all of your calls will, that will route
all your calls, sorry to wherever you are.
There's even a dial by name directory.
You're going to sound like a fortune
500 company and more importantly,
you'll never miss an important call
all front of 13 bucks a month. Dude,
this is a joke. If you have your own
business and you don't have a voice,
you're a moron. All right? Right now for
a limited time, I listened as his country,
he voice for free for 60 days.
You get this wonderful service
for two months for free, roughly,
unless it's back to back 31 days. Then
you got to watch out those last two days.
You to have to take your calls seriously.
My listeners get an extended 60 day
trial to test drive this amazing business
tool that is correct,
60 days.
Just for our listeners and whoever
else reads this on a podcast,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bill B I l l now to sign up,
set up your ear voice 60 day
extended free trial. Now, um,
he voice.com/bill,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash bill
and if you'd like to donate to this
podcast, everybody, whenever you're
going to buy something on Amazon,
uh,
just go to [inaudible] dot com click on
the podcast page and then click on the
Amazon link that we have, whatever you
call it, the little picture of Amazon.
You Click on that and it'll
take you right to Amazon.
And they kicked me a little bit of money
and, uh, it doesn't cost you a thing. Um,
why can't I get rid of this year?
Don't save.
Okay.
Alright,
back to this shit.
And I watched a really cool
documentary called Nixon on Nixon,
which is basically the tapes from the
White House that he set up the Nixon tapes
and then also interviews that he had.
And um,
this guy puts Archie bunker to shame,
you know,
but granted it's also like, I mean, the
guy taped himself for like six years,
however long he was in office. He had
one term and then he wanted the next one,
I think within a year or so he
was out, what, six 68 to 74,
basically five,
six years.
So of course all they pick out is
when he's saying antisemetic shared.
And when he's saying, you know, stuff
about minorities, his stuff about women,
I mean, Jesus Christ, this guy, like
he sounds like Archie bunker, but uh,
it's just a really fascinating thing.
I highly recommend it.
And um, just how like they
say the press is the enemy.
The press is the enemy and how you think
it's like this evil thing like this
sitting there going like, yes, we
must lie to the American people.
They're view is literally the press is
the enemy because they're distorting what
it is we're trying to say,
which is the classic thing where everybody
thinks that they're doing right and
it's the right thing. I'm a moron and
I enjoyed it and I think you will too.
Sure. We all do. Let's get to some
questions here this week. Um, oh,
by the way, I was in New York City,
uh, barely had time to do anything. Uh,
I went and I recorded, we, uh,
we got a big time actor to do
one of the roles on my show.
F is for family and had a
great time doing that. And A,
I can't fucking wait for
this show to come out.
We're doing the last records today and uh,
I'm not allowed to say,
I guess some of the people that we got
on this thing and we signed another
person to do it and yeah,
we're going to have to record
today. Yeah. Um, so anyways,
the stock market, uh, Billy
market belt, are you involved,
are you involved the,
Oh,
are you involved in the buying and
trading of stocks or mutual funds?
Do you have a business manager
diversifying your shit?
Come to San Diego and go fuck yourself.
That is an unbelievably personal
fucking question, but I'll answer it.
This is what I think about the
stock market. I think it's a, uh, I,
I just, I think it's, um, uh,
it's like Vegas,
it's just a crap table.
And I think insider trading happens all
the time and I think there's people who
go in and they drive the market up and
then they pulled their money out and it
falls down and then they fight.
They buy it low and they
do it all the fucking time.
And the same people that do that put
the money behind these campaigns for the
people who become president and
only make $500,000 a fucking year.
And that's why people look the other way.
And then once I,
if he fucking 20 years they
throw a celebrity chef in
jail to make it seem like
they're doing something.
Um,
am I in the stock market?
Uh, sort of, but not really.
I'm super conservative and uh,
I just look at my retirement account
that I just want it to still be there.
I'm not worried about it gaining interest.
I'm just more worried about the,
some of the money.
MMM.
But I don't look at my retirement
fund like it's even going to be there.
The way these bags of fucking
running wild is hulk Hogan says,
and nobody is trying to stop these guys.
And I've lately been fucking bitching
about why we're still having to fucking
wards over in the Middle East.
MMM.
And fighting fucking terrorist groups of
30 fucking people who don't even have a
fucking airplane.
You know what I mean?
Like they're going to come over here
and do something to us and like what?
Destroy this fucking company
and it causes a quadrant cost.
They could come over here and they
could fucking blow something up. Yeah.
All right.
We're going to survive that.
We need to spend billions of
fucking dollars over there
going after 30,000 fucking jerk offs,
you know?
Meanwhile you got insurance companies
and bankers raping everybody over here.
And then you got other people
poisoning the food supply.
You know,
what are they got there that dead,
the this so fucking powerful.
Like you're not even allowed to say what's
in the food. You got this dumb shit.
You watching the world series and they
have stand up for cancer and nobody's
talking about the fucking food supply.
And then if you criticize the,
I'm standing up for cancer, like you don't
give a shit about and they just start,
they always just start yelling at people
and they never yell at the fucking five
fucking guys that they could
actually change the shit. It's,
it drives me up the fucking wall.
It's like that.
Then hold their whole fucking
no more campaign is classic NFL
classic.
And it felt like there reprimanding you.
Like you were the one who didn't show
that whole fucking tape the Internet,
the very least they're trying to
say we're all guilty. It's like, no,
you're guilty. Get cunt. So whatever.
So that's what I see. I say bring the
boys and girls home and uh, you know,
we started a,
we invade the fucking people that are
putting all this crazy shit in the food
supply. I'd start with that and I'd
knock on some bankers house, you know,
you like, what the fuck
are you doing? You know,
that would make everybody's
life way better,
I would think
rather than going after fucking 5,000
people working out on a jungle gym bill,
you kind of over simplifying things. Well
that's what I do do. You don't like it.
Listen to another fucking podcast.
You want to listen to some of you read Ga,
go listen to Joe Rogan.
There's an informed human being.
All right, you listen to the Joe
Rogan experience to learn things.
You listen to my podcast to feel
better about yourself, to feel smarter,
you know?
Does that make you feel good
on that? You smarter than me?
Well fuck you. All right. Okay,
here we go. Farmer bill. Hey Bill.
Let's say the apocalypse goes down. Uh,
I take a steak knife and stick it in
my neck and I would hum a jingle bells.
And that's how I would end it. He
goes, oh, anyways, he goes, shoot,
you get to that farm and you
realize you only have three crops.
Oh, you, you get to that farm. What farm
did I say? I was going to have a farm.
No, Jesus, I didn't know what you are.
You already lost me two sentences in.
But I'll keep reading.
What do you grow?
You might be living off these three
fruits or vegetables for awhile.
So you gotta be smart.
Also,
you need to think about how
you might combine them to
change it up a bit. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself up. First of
all, I don't have to do any of that.
I didn't have to answer this fucking
question and I resent the fact that you're
telling me that I have to do
this when you can't even fucking,
you're writing sentences as bad as
I speak. Um, but I'll answer it.
I'll answer it. Um, so I,
when I get to vet farm and I, and if I
could have three crops, what would I grow?
Let's see here.
Okay.
I'd have to vegetables and fruit,
right?
That workout.
I guess I'd have some sort of lettuce.
Well, first of all, the
fruit. I like bananas.
It's very hard to get sick of bananas.
I could eat a banana every day. Boom,
banana, potassium, no matter
what. I'm going to end up
getting some sort of scurvy.
Right?
Okay.
I make maybe I need an orange.
Trying to think of all this shit and
what would happen when you get scurvy?
You know what, I, I can't answer it.
I, I'd have to read up on nutrition.
I didn't know that there was going
to be a test this week. Everybody,
if I was just going by taste,
I would have a banana,
uh, some sort of lettuce. And then what?
What's another vegetable that I like?
Yeah,
I dunno. Apples. Yeah. My,
so my vegetables would be a lettuce and
apples and then the fruit would be a
banana.
Today you go.
Now I want to ask everybody
who just listened there,
like how excited did you get that you
thought that I actually thought that an
apple was a vegetable,
you know,
and it made you feel better about
you and your fucking stupid life.
That full for one second you were
writing to somebody else was wrong.
What does that say about you as a person?
If you didn't actually just hear me say
that and then actually feel sad like,
oh no, oh no, he's going
to make a fool of himself.
If it actually made you fucking happy,
you know?
Do you think that I'm
going to wish you a happy?
I hope you fall face first into the gravy.
When you think about dad,
right in front of your mom and when you
pick up your fucking half burned up face
and you're pulling that lot off your face,
I would just love for you to see
the disappointment in her eyes.
That's what I want for you on this
wonderful week for giving thanks.
Um, Jesus Christ. How fucking
heavy handed and they going to be.
You know the NFL right?
This week when they do their fucking
Thanksgiving games, you know they,
they're going to have like a camouflage
fucking Turkey for the troops and then
you know there's going to be
something about some disease.
This is what they're gonna do.
They're gonna,
they're gonna say no more hitting
women with the camouflage Turkey leg
with a cancered riddle,
camouflage Turkey while supporting the
troops. That's what they're going to say.
I think they're going to combine
all of that. And at some point,
I imagine everybody's gonna
stand up for some, for something.
They're going to stand up for a disease.
I stand up for cancer.
Sounds like you support cancer,
doesn't it? Stand up for cancer.
Stand up for it.
How about it shouldn't be
stand up against cancer.
Am I slowly losing my mind and like,
I don't understand the English
language all of a sudden.
Am I getting some sort of a, I
dunno. I know. What the fuck.
I can't even, I didn't know what
the fuck to tell you. I just,
I just wish they would just play
the games. Just show the gay.
I don't need you to try to make
me be a better person. All right.
I'm a piece of shit and I'm trying.
Okay. And I need to be fucking like,
I don't need you be my fucking
parents. Right. Fireplace.
Uh, Billy clause. Uh,
I'm thinking of a, Oh,
what about Avocados?
Gotta love and Avocado.
Hey, I'm back. I'm back on my diet here.
This is how I lose weight. I juice
morning in lunch and then I tried to eat.
Fucking is Veggie as I came for
the rest of the fucking day.
And then you skip the rope. He skipped
her. Open up, melts off you. That's it.
Then you're done. Then you're in Billy
Bob Thornton shape. Alright. Fireplace.
Billy clause. I'm thinking fixing.
I'm thinking fixing up my basement.
You thinking of fixing up your basement.
The previous owner had a
fireplace plastered over.
It's either a traditional
fireplace or a wood stove.
Do you have any feeling of how I'm
supposed to assume and understand that
literally the way you wrote that and
mean it sounded like behind the wall was
either a traditional fireplace
or a wood stove. Mike, what the,
who the fuck would have a
woodstove in a wall? Um,
do you have any feet? Well,
maybe there is, is there,
when I think of a woodstove it's
sitting in the middle of a room. Have,
fuck now I gotta go. I gotta Google
image it. I got a Google image
when I'm going down the road.
You guys just enjoy this music while
I look this up. You fucking something.
Wonder why babe,
when I'm going down the road,
I used to do something soft wood stove.
I can't sit and type at
the same time image but B.
Yeah. What stove? Yeah. It sits
out in the fucking, there it is.
I'll do a Paul Versey does dude.
I Google what the stoves and none
of them were in a wall. Yeah.
None of them are in a wall.
Okay.
Hey,
some day I gave her ma,
but she wanted my soul.
Don't think twice.
It's all right. All right.
Fireplace. Say Billy clause.
I'm thinking of fixing up my basement,
the previous owner ahead of fire.
What fireplace plastered over it.
So it's either the traditional
fireplace or a wood stove.
That's how I should have written.
Do you have any feelings either way,
pros or cons on the, on the matter? Um,
okay.
Oh, I'd go into the wall, dude.
If you got a fireplace matter,
they don't allow him anymore.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't know where the fuck you live,
where you could actually
have a wood stove.
I didn't think that they
allowed that anymore.
Okay.
Or You could just have some shit
coming out of the chimney. Um,
but you know,
if you actually already have a fireplace,
if that system is already there.
Okay.
Yeah. But then the fucking
Jimmy's going to be fucked up.
Okay.
And then you have to fix that. I would,
you know, I would go the expensive route.
That's what I do.
Okay.
I would die. I would take it,
I would have the exposed brick.
This is the original brick from the early
1920s back when Babe Ruth was playing
in a softball league.
Dude,
they were doing the Charleston when the
guy was hitting home runs. I mean, Jesus,
give me a fucking break bat, Bat,
Bat, bat, yet up it up. Boom,
boom.
Like that was a hit song will blow the
yet yet that Danila do to fuck a woman
walking around wearing swimming caps.
Okay.
That's when guys that had
one piece bathing suits and
went down to your fucking
knees and they had just stripes across it.
Okay.
They need to have a fucking life guard.
You just went into the ocean and
you're drowned. And like that I was at,
nobody gets sued.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways. Uh, yeah, I
would, I would, I would.
Okay.
I would unearth the fucking fireplace.
That's what I would do. Um, anyways, hey,
we're still trying to raise money for
the all things comedy, uh, studio.
We're getting closer by the day.
We really appreciate everybody a,
your donation stand up for the new
all things comedy professional studio.
Um,
okay.
We would greatly appreciate it. Uh,
I'm excited. All things comedies.
A Ari Shaffir is taping a new
standup special this very week.
Uh, Joe Rogan, friend of
the Monday morning podcast,
he has a new stand up special that
just debuted on comedy central.
Please look for that. The
Great Joe Rogan. And um,
rumor has it that I might be out at the
Ice House with him this Wednesday night,
right before thanksgiving.
All right. And with that,
we're going to end with a
little holiday song. Okay. Have
Yourself, hey, happy thanksgiving.
Eat some Turkey for B mashed
potatoes and so fucking yams for you.
Yeah.
And don't get into a fight no matter
how much your brother's a dick,
hello people.
It's once again,
that time of year when Douche bags on
TV tell you to stop and think about
everything that you have.
You know,
millionaires on television sitting there
getting blown right before the take
that they did to tell you to sit back
and feel thankful for everything that you
have. This is the thing, you know,
it'd be a great goal is if you're
going home for Thanksgiving, okay.
Especially if you're in your college
years and you were still have fucking hate
my parents.
If you could just somehow go
there and not yell at anybody,
not get drawn into a fight.
Okay.
When one of your siblings who makes
those passive aggressive comments because
they're competing for the attention of
your parents because subconsciously they
realize that despite what your
mother says, you are her favorite.
Okay.
You know, you're just going to, I never
had kids, but it's a possible you've got,
I mean, you know, I love the
Bruins. I have my favorite player.
You know what I mean? Speaking of which
Jesus Christ, we've got to get healthy,
good Lord fucking loss
to the Canadians again.
MMM.
I actually sat down and I,
uh,
enjoyed the rangers beating
the shit out of Canadians.
Something that we haven't been
able to do this year, but you know,
you're going to have those left down case,
but the Canadians look good.
God Damn it. Those bastards look good. Um,
anyways. Yeah. So why don't you do that?
Okay.
Do that.
Sit down and have some fucking food.
I would love to have Thanksgiving this
year, but I got dusted my fucker ketchup.
Yeah.
Hear that. You hear the knocking
down stairs. People knocking.
Bunch of Kate come in. All right.
That's a podcast for this week.
I seriously have yourself a
a happy thanksgiving. Thank
you. Uh, you know what,
I'm thankful for that people
listened to this podcast. Um, oh,
and uh, you know what I announced,
I'm so frigging excited about this.
Um, I am um, oh Jesus the
hammer. It's coming now.
I uh,
yeah,
we, we announced the
uh, my Australian torque
on the Internet and now we've got
to get the dates up on my website,
but I am going to be going to basically
all the major cities in Australia except
for the one that begins with an a that
I got a bunch of shit from where people
were giving me Shit, you know,
for not going over there.
I'm just taking a 20 hour
fucking flight to Perth.
Can you also fucking come here? Why
don't you guys get on a Choo Choo train?
He do you guys even have
trains in Australia?
We able to build them or did the fucking,
everybody went to build
and get bit by a fucking,
some ridiculously inland's
something or other.
It has enough venom.
They killed 200 elephants because there's
no fucking food supply out of that.
So when they bite you, they got to make a
Sherry accounts. Um, yeah. Why don't you,
why don't you do me a solid and just,
you know,
I'll take a 20 hour flight and you can
jump on a fucking train for 45 minutes.
Drink some little creatures, beer. Oh Man,
I can't wait to drink that shit when I'm
over there. Oh, let me tell you bill,
he's going to get fat
when he's over there. Um,
and then I'm going to go to New Zealand
and I'm going to do two dates over there.
And a rumor has it that,
um,
I might be adding some Asia,
some Asia dates
onto this tour and uh,
to give you an hint,
to give you a hint.
MMM.
Let's see. How can I, let me see
if I know enough about any of these
countries to give you a hint. All
right. I'm going to give you a hint.
One of these,
I'm going to be going to the land.
Anybody who's English speaking in the
crowd will be either an ex patriot or a
telemarketer. All right? Come on.
People where the telemarketers
from when you call up,
hello, my name is Fike, right?
Where are they from? Um,
I'm going to do a stand up show in a
country where I could maybe possibly get
caned afterwards.
Ah,
quiver in butt cheeks over there.
Um,
I'm going to do stand up possibly
in a city where right off the coast,
there might be some right in the water,
right in the bay.
There might be some old army
helicopters under the water.
And then I'm also going to do
a show in a country where, uh,
oh Jesus Christ.
How do I fucking do this one?
I'm out of definitely
a bunch of ex patriots.
It's English speaking
in a country that Nixon
actually broke the science. Uh,
science broke the silence with one of
his big moves that he did during his
presidency was he actually went and had
a big meeting with these guys. All right,
there you go. It's going to
be an insane tour and, uh,
I'll probably lose money on most of the
nights, especially with those last ones.
I mean, I didn't, and you know, where
the fuck I'm going to be performing,
but I'm going, God damn,
why the fuck wouldn't shit?
That's it. And, uh, anyways,
everybody have a happy thanksgiving. Uh,
you know, come on. They're your family.
You love them.
Don't get drawn into the fights.
Tell everybody their food tastes
good and lets it go. Fuck yourselves.
And I'll talk to you next week.